[Music]
All right. So, prompt engineering is
dead. And this is a bold statement, but
I'm I'm saying that it never actually
existed. And if you've ever done h
prompt engineering, you probably know
that it's kind of because you
kind of try to ask the LLM to act nicely
and do what you want to do, do what you
wanted to do. And so uh this talk I'm
going to walk you through
a story of mine where I managed to
improve our kind of sample chatbot that
we have in our website. And I made it I
made I it was possible for me to make it
like uh 5x better without actually doing
any prompt engineering because you know
it's not really engineering right and so
we have a chatbot in our application in
our website it's rab based super simple
it just allows you to ask questions
about our documentation and it gives you
answers super simple super
straightforward the easiest rug you can
think about
and when I deployed it the first time it
worked uh kind of okay and I tried try
to make it work better and you can see
some examples here. I try to I I needed
to have him only answer things that
related to trace loop because this is my
company. I don't want you know it to
answer things about the weather or
something else. I wanted to answer about
trace loop only and I want it to be
useful. So if someone ask a question I
want the question to be useful for the
user who asked it and I wanted to make
less mistakes. It was making so many
mistakes and I wanted to just get a
little bit better and and so you know
what what are we doing at this stage?
with doing prompt engineering. But why
do I even need to iterate on prompts? I
just want to give give it a couple of
examples. this is good, this is bad and
have it somehow learn, you know, how to
how to follow my instructions properly
and always
and and so I begin imagining, you know,
I begin imagining I want to build this
automatically improving machine that
will be kind of like an agent that will
research the web, find the latest and
greatest prompt engineering techniques
and uh and then apply them to my prompt
over and over and over again until I get
the best prompt for my super simple rug
pipeline.
and and to do that to to run this kind
of machine I needed to uh do some a bit
more work right because I need we've
you've all been in a lot of
conversations here about evaluator so
you know that we need an evaluator so
that m crazy machine can actually know
how to improve and if it's actually
improving and so uh to do that I need to
create a data set of like questions I
want to ask my chatbot about the
documentation h and then I want to build
an evaluator that can evaluate how well
my rag pipeline is responding to those
questions. And then I have the agent
that's kind of like iterating on the
prompts until I get to the best prompt
ever. And so this is kind of like how it
will look like schematic, right? I have
the rank pipeline. I have the evaluator
and then I'm going to have my auto
improving agent. Let's begin. Rack
pipeline. Super simple. Have a chroma
database. have a open AI and some simple
prompts that you know take a question
find relevant documents in the chroma
database and just output an answer
uh so you'll see I'm just this super
simple one I just ask it a question how
do I get started with trace loop and
then it runs takes a couple of seconds
and then we're going to see an answer
and we're going to see the trace just so
you if you never if you've never seen a
rag pipeline and I'm guessing you also a
rag pipeline And you know this is how it
looks like right couple of calls to
OpenAI Chrome database and then you know
at final stage we get like a all the
context into OpenAI and we get the final
answer uh to the user was great and we
have a couple of prompts here we
probably want to optimize
this is not what I want to do
uh great
okay now let's go to the next step my
evaluator so what do we need for
evaluations this is not a talk about
evaluators I'm I'm sure you've heard a
lot of talks about evaluators in this
conference but I'm going to tell you
what what kind of evaluator did I choose
to use h so first you know you need a
data set of questions and and you know a
way to evaluate these questions and then
the evaluator is going to kind of invoke
the the rag pipeline and then get answer
from the rag pipeline and then going to
kind of evaluate and get a score maybe a
reason if why the score is low or high
and then this is kind of what we're
going to
for the agent will be the last step that
can auto improve uh the prompt.
And so you know there's couple of
there's a lot of types of evaluators. I
think we've been talking a lot about LM
as a judge. And I'm spoiler alert I'm
going to choose an LM as a judge here
because it's easier to build and it's
easier to deploy. But there are also a
lot of different types of evaluators
kind of like classic NLP metrics. you
know, if you want to do something which
is embedded based on or all of these
colors uh uh that can also help you uh
evaluate different types of tasks like
translation tasks and uh and even text
summarization tasks. And I think the
main difference that I see between, you
know, classic NLP metrics and LMG is
that classic classic NLP metrics usually
require some ground truth. And so I need
to have, you know, my questions and then
the actual answers. And then if I have
the actual answers when I'm invoking my
RAD pipeline, I can actually get, you
know, I can compare the ground truth
answer against whatever the RAD pipeline
return. Great. And then the LM is a
judge. They can work with a ground
truth. Sometimes you can build a judge
that can judge an answer based on some
real answer that you expect. But they
can also they can also uh try to assess
an answer just based on like the
question and the context without any any
ground truth. For my example because I I
know the data set and know everything.
I'm going to build a ground truthbased
LLM as a judge.
But before we're going to do that, I'm
going to talk to you about where can we
evaluate where can we run these
evaluators. Right? So if we have an
evaluator what can we evaluate? I'm
taking like I'm saying that I want to
evaluate my rad pipeline but what
exactly do I mean? So a rag pipeline is
basically two steps right we get the
data from the vector database and we run
the called open AI with some context
from the vector database. So we can kind
of evaluate each step separately. You
can evaluate each one and we kind of
call it like a unit testing right? We
can even evaluate how well the vector
database is fetching the data that I
need to answer the question or I can run
it on like the complete execution of the
rug. I can take the input the question
and take the answer the final answer
that I'm getting from the from the rag
pipeline and just evaluate how well the
answer is given that question and I can
also dive deeper into everything that's
happening in the internals look at the
context look at the question look at the
answer and everything all together try
to evaluate given the given the context
and given the question how well is the
answer performing
so again I'm going to do a simple LM as
a judge
And I'm going to take 20 examples of
questions that I've created. And for
each question, I'm going to write what
do I expect the answer to contain. So
it's going to have like three facts that
each the answer that was generated by
the right pipeline should have. And then
the validator is simply going to take
the answer that we've gotten from the
right pipeline and make sure that the
facts actually appear in the answer. And
so we're going to get, you know, per
each fact, we're going to get pass or
fail. So it's a boolean response and
then a reason. So if it fails, I'm I
want to see a reason like why the judge
thinks that the fact is not does not
appear in in the answer that we got. And
so then we're going to get a score which
is numeral which is great because we
like working with numeral scores which
is kind of like summarizing all the
facts across all the all the examples.
So we have three facts times 20
examples. It's 60 60 total facts that we
need to evaluate. I'm going to just
check how many facts were right out of
the total facts that we expected to have
in the rag generated answers. Uh so
let's see it in action. Uh and as you
can see this is like the questions and
the facts and everything. This is what I
uh I I created to to make sure that the
rug operates and then I'm going to run
it the evaluator and what you'll see
that the evaluator is doing is running
evaluations right. So it's taking
questioning the rug getting an answer
and then checking that answer against
each of the facts that I've given it and
then going to create a score and you'll
see the score you know slowly uh
progressing as I'm running the
evaluator. This is like a super slow
process and I don't have enough time to
actually show you it till the end but it
it works. It takes just a couple of
minutes.
Okay.
Okay. And and
Okay,
great. Less last step is our
uh agent. The agent that will optimize
the prompt. We have everything set up.
Now we can actually build the agent. So
I'm going to build a researcher agent
and it's going to take, you know, as I
said, a prompting guides online. It's
going to crawl the web. It's going to
find prompting guides. It's going to get
an initial prompt. And then it's going
to take, you know, it's going to take
it's going to run the evaluator once to
get like the initial score. And then if
we get the initial score, it's going to
get the reasons why we failed some of
the evaluations. It's going to combine
the reasons for failures plus prompting
guides to get a new prompt. And then
we're going to get a new prompt. And
then we're going to feed it back to the
evaluator, run it again, get a new
score, and then run it again with the
agent. So we can actually even improve
the score a bit more. If you've ever
done kind of ML, classic ML training,
this is kind of like a classic machine
learning training, but with a bit of
vibes.
Uh so let's see it in action. We're
going to I've used the crew AI uh for
for doing that and I'm going to kick off
and you can see it will take a couple of
seconds. We can actually see h the agent
you know thinking and then calling the
evaluator and then the evaluator will
run and get the responses and get the
score and I hope yeah I hope I can yeah
that's why it's running the evaluators.
is calculating the score and uh and then
you know the agent is running back that
I skipped a couple of minutes here and
then you know we got a response and then
now the agent the researcher agent is
trying to understand okay why the prompt
wasn't working kind of find ways to
improve rag pipeline based prompts and
then it's going to like regenerate new
new kind of like prompt with maybe a bit
more instructions or kind of best
practices how to write prompts and then
you see colleague the evaluator again to
get a a new uh a new score so we know if
we need to to optimize or not.
Great.
Okay, this is when I run it once. I
actually this the initial score was was
okay was 0.4 for and I run it just two
iterations and I got like a really like
a long kind of prompt that you expect
like to see from like someone who's done
a lot of prompt engineering is like give
it a lot of instructions and telling it
how to how it should react and like how
it shouldn't. You're like an expert in
in answering users questions about trace
loop. It was really nice to see it
happening without me having to I write a
lot I wrote a lot of code to make the
agent work but I didn't do needed I
didn't need to do a lot of prompt
engineering. I didn't do any prompted
engineering, right? So, it kind of
worked. It was really, really nice. And
the score actually jumped by a lot. And
I stopped at 0.9 because it means that
like 90% of the of the facts were
correct. Great. I can stop.
So,
if there's something you want to get out
of this talk is that you can also vibe
vibe engineer your prompts. You not you
don't need to manually iterate in
prompts. You just need to build
evaluators and then you kind of can run
gradient ascend gradient ascend on your
evaluator. So you have your score you
can kind of slowly try to optimize on
your score either automatically with an
agent like I did or manually by just
like uh reading those manuals about how
to write the best prompts and then
fixing them again and again and again.
Some future thoughts to to wrap it up.
We have two minutes. Okay. Um am I
overfitting? So I have 20 examples and
then I run the evaluator. So maybe maybe
maybe the prompt that I'm getting will
work really well for those 20 examples
but then if I give it like another
example it will be horrible. So yes, I
was overfitting them because I just gave
it the entire 20 20 examples. Ideally
would have more examples and then kind
of like again classic machine learning
split it into train test uh sets or
train test evo sets and then run them
like separately, right? You you take the
train set this is what you're trying to
optimize but then you also use the test
set to make sure that you actually you
you're not overfitting to your uh
training data set, right? So you don't
want to give the optimizer too much
context or unless it just will know how
to answer those specific questions and
nothing else.
H I told you that prompt engineering is
dead but I've actually done a lot of
prompt engineering for this demo because
I needed to engineer the agent that is
optimizing my prompts. So I have it was
horrible but I've done a lot of prompt
engineering for that. Maybe maybe I can
also do this work for the evaluator
prompts or even for the agent prompt.
It's kind of like this meta talk where
who's even writing prompts here? Like
I'm using the agent to optimize itself.
Maybe it will work, maybe it won't. I I
might try it some weekend. It's kind of
interesting.
Uh some links you can try this out. Uh
it's available in our repo. It's trace
loop/autoprompting
demo. And you can run it. Uh it should
run. Uh I tested it yesterday. And if
you have any questions, you're welcome
to ask me uh outside or you can even
book some time with me just by uh not
clicking this link but just following
this link. Thank you very much.
[Music]